yeah how are you doing guys good to see
you all welcome back for the fourth time
the fourth time the fourth one the big
one yeah the big one yeah big one
how you guys doing yeah doing all right
yeah
another episode of chris tries not to
get cancelled yeah yeah
in japan times i was described as
affable
right
since i'm thinking of rebranding to
affable and japan
but i'm not just affable in name i'm
in nature i don't know
what does it mean
it's somebody who's approachable
affable
approachable relatable why not just say
approachable approachable in japan like
a male karen well i'm afraid and i've
bought christmas presents it's a little
bit late oh yes it's a february it's
february chris what are you doing
it's definitely not the 21st of december
we're filming this in i've been camping
out the front of the studio for a whole
month waiting to be allowed my fault
anyway did you wrap those presents
yourself oh my god you actually wrapped
them up i am laughable
who's got what the what's this one
the other one wrapped up uh i forgot
which one's which is the worst [ __ ]
center ever you just like at the kid's
house like [ __ ] uh well one of them is
yours
yeah oh there's there's gone oh thank
you very much
uh animation that's you that's me
animation
it says
insulting artwork of me looking like a
[ __ ] bowling ball against us well we
want you to uh confirm your victory for
the most trip in the uh yeah yeah
this year so we got you some drip chris
thank you very much guys trash
yeah open your presents then let's get
this out of the way should we do one at
a time or just um go all together well
this let's start with joey
all right so i asked the man so heavy i
asked the man at the toy store what all
the kids want this christmas
and this was what he said oh well you
picked her right because uh i've always
wanted this there you go it's the mario
kart
go card
that's actually a princess
you got batteries and i got batteries
first time where batteries are included
thank god
is this the one that i played around in
your studio no it's not as expensive as
that one
it's the tube [ __ ] you could drive that
around and uh drive aki mental hell yeah
it's such a cool toy yeah oh yeah
this is a shared present with you in
sydney uh you've got a new place
and uh
i figured thank you very much i thought
that was a bottle of wine
i honestly thought this was a bottle of
water
we've been looking for kitchen
appliances because we are
you can connor's like when i come to
your house i can take all your money
well you know i didn't i did beat you uh
poker
for legal reasons we need to say we
don't obviously bet money on progress
yeah because yeah because gambling is
illegal yeah [ __ ] heavy chips made up
maybe next time you could beat me at
poker now you can practice at home
next time wait he beat you a poker no i
beat him okay he needs to practice i i
beat him as well i'll be destroyed he's
rubbish right you know we were getting
it was the night was going on long i'd
already collected all the money
that's just let's just let's just all or
nothing let's come on the night's over
and then chris won and then here now he
won't let me forget it
that's not what happened we went for two
hours it was 11 o'clock p.m 11 p.m when
we started yeah and connor was winning
for the first hour what time did this
place closed what time is it open was
that until one someone will stay all
night we'll play and he did really well
he was doing really well to be fair he
annihilated this poor japanese twice
twice and he bought back in sheepishly
got annihilated again i was like oh i
said i'm just too good
and then i was like bidding my time i
done quite badly and connor was like
come on chris you got to step up your
game mate i i i
thought chris didn't know how to play
poker for the first hour because she
didn't do anything and then i had a good
i think it was like ace king yeah yeah
and i was like plus a good hand and i
was like putting some chips like all in
i was like cool and connor was like
exactly like that and then i went
wherever he got he went nothing and then
he lost or he kind of like decimated his
pile
which probably got home
what time is the first place this also
wasn't for money uh there's some there's
a lot of place in japan you can just
gamble
fake money which you can't buy anything
yeah it's it's like it's a show so
monopoly money then yeah i didn't know
that at the time i thought we could get
money or we couldn't get money i thought
you could like get drinks or something
with it yeah you can't get anything like
drink vouchers and stuff yeah yeah i
think now you can get him no because i
think even drink vouchers is not oh
yeah because there's a big poker scene
weirdly in japan there's a bunch of
poker places in uh shinjuku around the
area well i mean there was talks there
was talks of opening that casino in
yokohama all right recently and then the
yokohama government was like um no
actually we need room for pachinko
machines yeah i think it would be good
for japan to get casinos i think
they can realize how [ __ ] pachinko is
yeah get rid of these noisy [ __ ]
places it's the worst the day the day
they introduce casinos in japan is the
day gacha dies
or it levels
what do you mean you can win this thing
called money yeah chance machines that
doesn't make that make sense i'd like to
imagine that all the poke tables are
themed after like the yu-gi-oh arm
things it's like
hit me up
it goes on the thing i would play poker
if i was keeping one of those right you
don't win money you win life points yeah
how amazing is that you just change life
points for money
there's so much hypocrisy in japan with
that if i don't understand how they can
be a big poker scene in japan if you
can't win money i just well i didn't
know that before i played i thought
we're gonna walk out billionaires
the guy was like you've got well done
and he gave me like some monopoly money
can i can i get a drink of this he's
like no you can't do anything get out
that's why you've won one million
zimbabwe dollars you are now a
millionaire it's like 50 usd i was
pretty disappointed but i'd beat connor
and that was enough
for chris well the one that you guys
went to which is the same one that we
went to i did take you there yeah was uh
like you get monopoly it's like a like a
block right like a plastic block you get
that you can exchange back to play
another round of pokemon yeah right
so you win
yeah
so what you win is just the chance to
compete together yeah yeah
you get to it's like it's like a it's
like a play for free pass
basically
sorry do you have to pay to play in the
place yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so
you have to buy it we paid like 40 bucks
to play thinking that maybe we could get
a drink or something yeah we didn't
really i mean it's too fair it's on us
for not knowing yeah but yeah no it's
you you can just play again in future if
you happen to go back to the same bar in
the exact same place and you remembered
to bring your piece of paper that says
you had money which i did
i use it to beat joey they're probably
like different we started we started we
started playing pokemon he was like
three times as many chips as me at the
beginning because it was like four
japanese men's uh all entire earnings
that i'd gotten then getting to chris
so you can't even exchange it for prizes
or anything like that alistair pacheco
you can exchange yeah that's what i was
thinking right sure yeah surely if you
could do pachinko there must be some
weird work around where you can you
could if you wanted to but maybe it's
not worth it well that's what i saw i
think but i think the pachinko one
typically is in another building right
it is a cash out yeah you cash in your
balls and then conveniently just around
the corner there's someone that wants to
buy your balls and that sounds really
wrong and i regret saying that now
and he'll he'll purchase yourself what a
coincidence i want those balls he's five
hundred dollars i actually need ball
bearings funny enough i've been
starting my own factory yeah pachinko is
a strange thing i hate porsche cake yeah
i feel like it it's
it's so it's such a blight on the
countryside as well oh yeah yeah yeah
every countryside in japan is like just
depressed there's nothing the business
is dying yeah except for the the palace
of pachinko though
like really [ __ ] booming when it
comes economically because there's a
pachinko parlor in the middle and then
all the businesses surround the pachinko
it's really sad i i got like
brag i've got like the number one video
on pachinko right yeah and you watch it
and you just don't understand why
because people play pogenko i i i made
it and i just don't get it can you play
pachinko i mean that thank you
we played it on my video
i gotta say like pretty [ __ ] boring i
didn't really play it you know i've
never felt like an irl auto play game
until i played pachinko yeah exactly you
know yeah you you turn a knob and that's
and that's it it's is that gameplay does
that count as gameplay it's like it's
like the subtle like wrist movement oh
it's places itself
it's brilliant in the video though i did
i'd natsuki and he was like he's an
unprofessional
professional player really and we gave
him i think like a thousand balls we had
to see how many could get in half an
hour and to be fair to him he did get
like four thousand and he kind of had a
strategy
just just luck because
it's a it's a 91 degree angle
you've got a 90 degrees bollocks i'm
sure there is but like why is like you
know you just get like wrist cramps
after like 10 minutes of playing it's
awful
i don't get it man yeah it's not fun i
don't i don't
understand fascination i feel like it's
because it's the only form of gambling
they have so yeah it just works oh
gotcha
that's not gambling you don't win money
well you don't win one in pachinko
either right you do yeah you win prizes
win prizes yeah you're in money no you
can't win money
you can get money no
you can change the balls for money you
can't yeah you can only exchange for
prizes otherwise it becomes a legal
gambling yeah yeah that's that's that's
how they get around that's how they get
around it pachinko isn't technically
gambling because you can't win money you
just win prizes yeah which you can then
expect yeah you can win you can win
prizes
you win prizes which you then exchange
for money i know in the building itself
you can exchange the prizes but i know
if you want money you have to go to the
other building right i miss it yeah yeah
so you can in the building itself you
can get like a bag of crisps for 10
balls but if you want to change the
balls for money you go to the other
building i always thought it was you get
the balls you exchange them for prizes
and then you go to another building and
you exchange the prizes for money
no i thought that's what i thought that
was the work around no i'm not certain
it's money
can we can we fact check this please the
debate
because either way there is some legal
loophole yeah this is there's a legal
loophole it's getting taken advantage of
here because if so it is illegal to play
pachinko for money in japan but there
are loopholes around japan strict
gambling laws some stemming from the
belief that the japanese must okay the
ones can well yeah the the uh yeah you
can you can get money from pachinko oh
no
that's the loophole yeah
it's illegal it's illegal to win prizes
directly from the game yeah but so
that's where the prize
i know
yeah that's not what i was arguing i
said you can get money from it you just
go to the building outside
but that's where the loophole comes in
yeah yeah that was never in contention
so they're basically if they if they
bring in a casino
so basically if they bring a casino to
japan they have to do the same thing
unless they change the laws yeah it's
like you win blackjack and you win a
teddy bear places have changed laws
before it's not beyond comprehension i
think this is japan
basically you get the uh the amount of
like for example the receipt that says
that this is the amount that you get for
a certain token yeah so this token you
can't exchange it for money within the
safety yeah yeah
i mean there are people who play crane
games right so it's pretty much the same
those people